all right sidra yeah it's a
where'd you grow where are you from
originally um i'm originally from
um new mexico oh cool yes
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents yeah so um i
have both my parents both my parents are
still married
so i had a pretty i guess what you call
wholesome vanilla
childhood grew up in a really small town
um you know just
had you know small public school really
it was kind of like a small government
town so everybody that lived there
had a parent that probably worked for
one of the labs or something so it was
kind of like a hush
hush kind of but a good childhood deal
yeah but really nice childhood um and i
spent most of my childhood as a dancer
um so i think i started dancing
pre-professionally when i was 10 years
old so that was kind of
basically from then on out that was
rebelling yeah ballet
modern that was kind of like the focus
um
that kind of took up most of my time as
a kid that's great
yeah it's good to have a focus or a
sport or something like that
yeah i was i was really shy until until
i
was an adult so um that was kind of a
good outlet for me because i was really
energetic um
so it just worked out really well
creatively and
your life went in what direction after
that you
so um then what happened i
so you know i was dancing um for most of
my life i started dancing professionally
um ended up you know kind of typical
like millennial my parents didn't like
force me to go to college but kind of
you know like you know
pushed me in a corner and uh you know
didn't want me to be an artist
so i ended up studying business
while i was still dancing professionally
and i was living in albuquerque at the
time which was a really
interesting place for me um
looking back on it now being a sex
worker um
like my time in albuquerque was
very like anti-sex work anti-sexual
um i always felt like i needed to
cover myself up and not be um
sexually provocative um just kind of
like based on just like the area in the
region
and um dealing with a lot of
uh just like bad situations with a lot
of like sexually aggressive men and it's
kind of just
the culture out there um so that really
definitely shaped me and it's
interesting to
come into like thinking about all of
that and then going into sex work as i'm
older and living on the west coast in
this like free
is your personality fairly free and
you're not inhibited uninhibited yeah
well
you know i it's kind of funny i i used
to be
that way and like very driven towards
just kind of like living for today and
not really thinking about tomorrow
um ironically again and like not what
you think about getting into sex work i
feel like my
my trip into getting into sex work was
actually
not within that lifestyle i feel uh you
know i feel like
um i i must have a much more controlled
lifestyle and a much more
um planned way of getting into things
now that i'm in sex work and i'm a
little older and
mature about things you're fairly new to
the industry right i'm very new yes how
long have you been doing this
um so i shot my first film um this
summer
so let's see it is december so it's been
um just shy of five months that i've
been in the industry it's
brand new brand new yeah how did you get
in or how did you
decide or how did you get into it it's
really weird so i
you know it's funny because it's we're
still in 2020
um and thinking back to myself uh you
know i
the first three months out of the year i
had a normal uh
nine to five business job management job
um never in my life i mean i always
thought you know like oh maybe i'd get a
sugar daddy or something i feel like
every girl is like i'm cute
shouldn't i have a rich old man giving
me money but never in a million years
thought i'd
get into any kind of sex work especially
mainstream porn where i'm
out on the internet everywhere for a lot
of people to see
uh but you know i lost my job in march
and i was really just worried it was you
know it was a time it was taking a long
time
for my unemployment checks to come in
and i was starting to run out of money
um
and i was really horny like i'm sure a
lot of people were
so i ended up starting camming because
it was just something that
like i kind of have an exhibitionist
kink um so like it kind of just like
satisfied that and i was like oh if i
can make a couple extra dollars
too like why not it looks like these
girls make money and i ended up um
kind of right off the bat was making
better money than i was working my
60 hour a week management job
um and was like oh wow and it also just
ended up being a really nice freeing
experience i feel like
because the world was over i was kind of
allowing myself
to break free of this wall of
um not openly displaying my sexuality
um and i feel like it was kind of just
like a gift that i've been hiding from
the world for
so you always had this exhibitionist in
you absolutely well and just
um just this you know i i've always had
um
just a really big gift of sensuality
um that yeah again i feel like i've
always restricted um
and so anyway so i got into uh
took some pictures uh got offered a
random gig
uh for porn out of the middle of nowhere
and was like wait for how much
oh that sounds fun um and then never
heard back about that but kind of just
had the seed planted um and i think
you know it's been a while since i've
really been able to perform
be a performer and call myself a
performer that's
uh you know that being my my formal
occupation even though i've still
continued to dance
um so the idea of being able to be a
performer again was really exciting so i
ended up
reaching out to an agency and you know
within my first month i think i got
booked for
about nine shoots uh and it's just it's
been really awesome i've been really
like it's just uh i really opened up
sexual uh sexually
uh it's been a good experience
absolutely well yeah for the most part
it's been um
it's been an experience of trial and
error but i think what i like most about
it
is that nobody else has control of my
future
or my uh my brand except for myself
and there's something that's been really
nice about that especially coming from a
corporate world where i had
you know every kind of limitation
keeping me from doing the work that i
need to do
so um it's just interesting that a lot
of people look at sex work as something
that
uh because sometimes sex work is
something that people do
out of necessity um but for me it was
something that i did
out of opportunity if anything else
so yeah but you also had the inclination
to do this kind of work anyway your
personality
absolutely yeah because i think a lot of
a lot of
people men and women would get eaten up
and
chewed up and spit out absolutely yeah
no i mean i i think part of it like i
i've i've grown to be very independent
um and i don't
i spend 99 of my time alone
so the idea of just being able to go out
and have sex with people for work
this is your social life it's yeah it's
it's a really nice additive to a social
life um
and you know it it keeps having sex
you know the idea of having sex with a
bunch of people all the time it keeps it
very simple as well
because even if you're dating someone
that's also doing the same thing
that also that comes with a lot of hurt
feelings i'm sure at the end of the day
does this does this new career get in
the way of your personal life
um romantic way kind of well
no because like well i like i guess i
could say yes but like it's kind of
non-existent
um so that's kind of why i felt like it
was something really easy to dive into
like just like feet first because i
i haven't um
just in the personal life that i've had
the past couple of years i
i live very i'm very strange for my
family
like not not emotion you know personally
but just like physically
um i haven't had a significant other in
a long time so if anything it's helped
my personal life thrive a little bit
more
are there any downsides to this career
sounds like it sounds like you're
enjoying it
the money is fairly good um yeah it's
like for you the the downsides is that
at the end of the day
um and i i'm still
learning this and i forget this you know
i came from
like a you know corporate job where
people like
people find a way to [ __ ] you over in
that way but you know
the sex industry is still a hop skip and
a jump away from
the hustlers on the street you know and
so
[Laughter]
i i i've just definitely
learned a lot from my mistakes
uh healthy i'm 27 27
yes um you know when you're
when you're selling stocks there's
always going to be someone that's going
to try and take advantage of you there's
i mean when you're selling anything
there's always going to
be someone that's going to try and take
advantage of you but especially sex
yeah i mean there's another layer to
what you're giving
absolutely we're giving up for money
like if i work at a
department store as i just mentioned to
someone else i interviewed from your
industry
you're still selling yourself your time
or your energy or whatever
but with what you're doing you're doing
that in addition you're almost like
i mean in some ways
intimacy sex is is synonymous with your
soul
i like that i was like you're selling
that exactly well yeah because
you're giving a part of yourself to
someone that that's uh
again it's an intimate experience it's
like for example um
you know you don't just go around
that's the neighborhood um
i'm trying to think like uh
say that you know you you don't sell
your emotional experiences without
with everyone or you don't give those
away for free and when someone
you know it's the same kind of thing
it's like someone taking away
something very intimate and special to
you for free is different than someone
taking an object
from you for free but at least in your
industry i assume everyone's doing it in
a respectful
somewhat dignified way right for the
most part but again i i i
i it definitely takes a good gut
instinct and i i'm really happy that
um i came into the industry i i you know
i'm kind of definitely a lot older
for you know for a girl getting into the
industry um and having coming from
my past living in albuquerque and
dealing with a lot of
sexual sexually aggressive men sexual
abuse and that kind of stuff
really taught me um
when i came into this industry to trust
my gut feeling
um and know that at the end of the day
like everyone's kind of methodical
that was something interesting that i
learned from caming is that you have
especially when you're brand new you
probably have about a hundred guys
if you're online enough you have 100
guys a day trying to scam you and you
you learn patterns and stuff
um just a bit you know like they try and
get a free skype show
and anything that they can get out of
you try and get out of you for free
um you know a lot of guys if like a girl
doesn't know how to use
hold on
[Music]
thank you sorry oh no worries that you
know
there's so many men on the internet
trying to pose as agents as
experts as this that or the other thing
um as a man with money
and they're very sophisticated ways of
doing it but you eventually learn
patterns um
so i i i that's kind of i'm learning
that in person
in porn um there's a lot of content
shoots now which has made porn very
kind of complicated the porn industry
because you don't have professional
companies all the time booking you for
shoots you have
another performer that wants to make
content with you that you both can
potentially make more money than on a
certain platform
but what comes with that is it's just a
lot of
men blurring the lines of oh i want to
have sex with you versus i want to make
content with you
something's going on oh sorry um so
that we'll see how that continues to
complicate the sex industry because i
have already myself
uh you know been roughed up a little too
much during a content shoot
and had you know heard numerous stories
of a lot of girls doing the same thing
and you don't have the kind of
protection of having
a full set of a director pas and all of
these
other people to make sure that nothing
so it's just like you and some
some guy a lot of times yeah and so um
i'm interested to see how like that's
gonna
that that's like a really interesting
interesting part of the
the porn industry that i um i'm still
learning do you find you you need your
intuition to be
heightened exactly and i i i i just
wonder about
what would happen had i gotten to this
earlier and i
you see a lot of girls that get into bad
things and it's it's too bad because a
lot of it's just
immaturity or just lack of understanding
do your what emotions do you do does it
bring up for you
i mean do you get depressed sometimes or
do you get angry or i mean
yeah it brings a lot of anger just
because at the end of the day
um there's really nothing that you can
do about it i i guess
well maybe that's like anger i've always
felt um you know i dealt with some
sexual abuse when i was in my early 20s
um and like domestic abuse and like
and then you know what the metoo
movement and then a lot of
stuff came out this summer um in porn
and really kind of reshaped and
uh started a new conversation in the
mainstream porn industry
but at the end of the day all i can
think is like it doesn't really matter
like nothing's really going to change
so i suppose that emotion comes
from out of frustration
if nothing else but i hope that there
are a lot of people out there that don't
feel the same as i do
it's a shame that humans are so mean to
each other it's a shame but i mean if
you look at children
and just like the amount of hate that a
you know a
a child without you know that kind of
anxiety that you learned to get as an
adult
um i think it's just in us unlimited
can we learn it from our families or
i don't i don't know i i i
it's hard to say because maybe but kids
i think kids learn it from other kids
um or parents or whatever parents but
yeah
perhaps uh
but yeah i don't know i
i guess i'm just more of a pessimist
i do believe there's there's goodness
and bad in everyone but no
do i i mean unfortunately
you uh i just got a twitter this year
which is the worst
decision i've made in 2020 and like that
you can really see
how genuinely mean people can get yeah
so
social media commenting oh yeah
absolutely especially when you don't
have application it's just awful
yeah well for the most part my channel
is pretty good well yeah
but the majority of my commenters are
very evolved and compassionate
but they're still the riff raff that oh
yeah but i don't know i mean
but i i think
hate gets kind of addicting because i i
see it in myself
uh it's i
regularly especially during covid where
i'm locked down at home and i just have
my computer to look at
um i find myself i have to take breaks
because i just like get addicted to like
finding information to just like feed
into that anger and i know i'm not the
only person exactly
and you have to and you know and i have
to take breaks i mean you just use logic
because hate accomplishes
nothing nothing exactly but you know
it's positive i mean
it'll just bring on more hate and if
that's what you want then sure if if you
if there's something you hate and you
express yourself about how awful it is
you're just
feeding putting fertilizer on it exactly
but it's interesting how addictive that
can be
and um and i see that happen in the
industry
in this industry to me all i see is it
makes me lose sleep or stresses me out
so i just turn it off and it's done
done well you know that's the smile
i'm an oddball um yeah i know i mean i i
i
we'll see i also just moved to los
angeles too so my
porn my my porn uh we're going through a
lot of transitions here
yes my porn transition is also coming
into los angeles where like i live my
life very based on like natural healing
and stuff and being
um stuck in a giant bubble with millions
and millions of people
is very stressful take it's a
it takes a lot of mental work to be able
to reside here
i feel like it's like you know how
um when you you know at the top of the
ocean there's the waves crashing down
and they're really
uh loud and crazy and heavy and then you
go about 10 feet below and everything's
nice and calm and still
right i mentally have to put myself
there every day to live in los angeles
where is that this is los angeles is
yeah big cities
so yeah and perhaps that's
i and you know and we're living in a
very very hateful time too
yes we are that's a shame it's a big
shame
well cedric i wish you the best of luck
with your new career thank you
you seem fairly well suited to doing it
but
yeah i just hope that those the horror
stories you're experiencing don't
continue
yeah we'll see i know you know and i
hope they don't continue for other
people in the industry i hope that sex
work can eventually become something
that
um is seen as positive and not something
that needs to be brushed under the rug
yeah i'm not sure what the i'm not sure
what the answer is
we'll see we are in america so i'm not
sure if there is an answer
that's right all right so dr thank you
so much for
coming in and talking thank you good
luck thanks
that was fun cool yeah i always get off
on tangents
yeah it's kind of cool when somebody's
intelligent enough to be able to do that
which you are obviously but